jlptの勉強をやめる日本人の彼女を
借りるあじゃなくて作る死観光する
ドラえもんを見るしたらね彼がジャイアン
みたいにごめんジャイアンって何お風呂に
入る頻度を高める周りを見て判断する鈴木
さんはどう思いますあやはり聞こえるよう
に息を吸い込む勤勉に働く遠回しに否定
するいやあの好きじゃないわけではないん
ですけどあのなんて言うのかなロスと
ニューヨークに旅行する楽しかったね今度
はハワイに行きたいね再確認するそして念
のためにもう1回確認するBじゃなくて
チーンという音が出る電子レンジを買う
青いタープを買ういや青じゃなきゃダメな
んだ堂々と本を盗むあじゃなくて立ち読み
する商品にエコモードを追加する眉毛を
整える1皿に収まる料理をあえて4皿に
分けるお箸で物を切れるようになる初めの
言葉を言う投資口座に入っているお金を
全部保険口座に移すあらゆる発言を脳で
始めるいやあびっくりしましたねいや全く
同感ですいやあ楽しそうだねいやあそう
ですね水を飲む時のグラスをもっと小さく
する英語を勉強し直すあ勉強のきっかけ
ですか今度ロスに行くんです力を使う時に
必ず決まりもこを言うはいよっしゃTNK
SRSとにかく省略する滅多にない休みを
同僚のためのお土産買い物をして過ごす
エビ煎餅でいいかあでも鈴木さん採用して
磨く遠慮する手帳を買うモスハを始める
褒め言葉の受け止め方を
忘れる